we have the option from Microsoft
Research completed his PhD from the
University of Washington and he's gonna
tell us about practical applications
um thank you shy for the introduction
and I wanted to thank the organizers for
their work organizing this workshop and
for inviting me to give a talk and thank
the audience for tuning in
so yeah today I'll be talking about
practical applications of homomorphic
encryption so this can be kind of viewed
as a continuation of the talks earlier
this morning where we use these
state-of-the-art homomorphic encryption
schemes in practice by that I mean that
it should be advancing the
state-of-the-art for privacy preserving
protocols so this is based on joint
works with a large set of Awesome
co-authors so let me jump to the roadmap
so first I will start by review and give
a short introduction to homomorphic
encryption and then I'll talk about
different case studies about applying
homomorphic encryption to build
privacy-preserving protocols so I will
give three examples first one is
oblivious Ram and second one is secure
matrix multiplication protocol waste
asan is mature xxx which is relatively
recent work and the third one is multi
key homomorphic encryption and private
inferencing so first let me give a
background on homomorphic encryption so
I think alaria and yong-soo may have
already covered a lot so I'll go by just
you know in a quick fashion and at least
let me know if you have any questions so
what is homomorphic encryption so we
will just refer to as HC from now on in
this talk and it is a new kind of
encryption technology which allows any
party to compute
encrypted data directly without
decrypting it first
so when we usually say homomorphic
encryption nowadays it means that we can
do additions negation and multiplication
of encrypted values so if we combine all
these operations that mean that we can
evaluate actually any multivariate
polynomial in either encrypted or plain
text entries so here there's a little
picture showing that if we encrypt these
numbers seven and five they will become
kind of random looking strings and there
is a addition procedure which is not
perhaps the simplest addition of the two
numbers that all puts another random
looking string with the good property
that if you decrypt that random looking
string in the end it will be the
addition of the two it originally
encrypted values and the same thing
works with the multiplication so this is
quite amazing protocol and but
surprisingly it's a it's achieved in
relatively recent time so before 2009 we
only have additive homomorphic
encryption
examples include pious games and DGK
schemes and others I want to list all of
them the feature of these schemes is
that they will support one of the two
operations from addition and
multiplication but they will not support
both so there are a lot of applications
which can be built upon these schemes
but it's still a little bit limited and
then in 2009 we had the first fully
homomorphic construction given by a
creek Gentry and kind of internal to
this construction is engineers
bootstrapping procedure which really
allows you to do arbitrary computation
and I should say like the another
important ingredient is that their
previous additive homomorphic encryption
schemes are mostly based on traditional
hardness assumptions
whereas
fhd construction is based on lattice
assumptions and since then there has
been a significant body of work
optimizing the homomorphic encryption
schemes in terms of performance
ciphertext size and some of the good
examples include the pgb scheme and pfy
schemes and tfhe and cks so currently
the homomorphic encryption scheme
landscape is that it can be very
efficient if you want to compute some
low depth circuits which if you
translate to the polynomial point of
view will be multivariate polynomial
with small degree and by very efficient
I still mean that we don't have the
efficiency for plaintext computation but
the overhead is about maybe four to five
orders of magnitude which may seem big
but if you compare with the original
homomorphic encryption scheme of Gentry
it's a big leap of performance
improvement
okay so what are some of the use cases
of homomorphic encryption so one of the
use case that people can think of easily
is the outsource computation so in this
case a client may have a computation it
wants to do on its data but the data
itself is sensitive so in order to
outsource this task the client could in
principle encrypt all its data and send
it to an untrusted cloud the cloud will
execute the computation unencrypted data
and then return an encrypted result and
only the client can decrypt the result
and get the computations that so this is
one of the use case and the other use
case is secure two-party computation
which has been studied since the
eighties I guess and in this situation
we have two parties each holding a
private input and they want to jointly
compute a function on their private
inputs without revealing their input to
the other party so there has been a lot
of techniques like gobble circuits or
other protocols based on secret sharing
to achieve secure two-party computation
but in homomorphic encryption case we
can use basically the same picture as
the left where we have one of the
parties encrypt its input and send it to
the other party which does the function
evaluation with its own private input so
here this private input can be thought
as just constants of the multi-bear
polynomial that we we have mentioned
okay so this looks pretty good so I'm
just gonna give a quick overview of the
state of the Arts aichi schemes so I
wanted to first mention that I don't
think there there's a clear winner of
which scheme is the best because it
seems like each scheme is good for
certain applications and for example if
we talk about bgv and bf3 schemes and
they're good for vectorized operations
over finite fields or like finite
domains in general and you can achieve a
similar performance guarantee with Sica
care scheme and for tfhe it is good for
operation on the individual bit level so
if you want to perform and say equality
checks or comparisons it may be a good
candidate for for these kind of
applications and the current performance
benchmark is that it takes 30
milliseconds to evaluate a binary gate
so and then there's the ckq scheme which
has the nature of doing approximate
computations so it also supports this
vectorization making it very desirable
for large scale applications like
machine learning and so here I have
included some performance numbers and
you can see that per multiplication or
per addition the overhead is still it's
kind of small and the the Secchia scheme
is different from the previous two
schemes that the computation is
approximate which means that the every
operation will introduce some precision
loss and it's a interesting open
question to do the precision control but
we won't go into too much detail about
that in this talk okay so
so another topic that comes up a lot in
this official discussion is that there
is a distinction between effigy and
somewhat as a chi or effigy and in the
sum what they see we have the
computation overhead and ciphertext size
which increase with the desired degree
of polynomial and this means that if we
want to do more and more complex
computation then we need to have bigger
and bigger HD parameters which means
that the performance overhead will be
worse and so this means that sh t is not
a very good candidate if we want to do a
very complex operation like machine
learning training or inferencing on a
very kind of like multi level neural
network for example and so the effigy in
the literature sometimes also referred
to somewhat ht+ this bootstrapping
procedure so here because bootstrapping
is an expensive operation the overhead
of fhe can be larger than sh e in the
beginning but the overhead actually
stays constant because we don't have to
select the parameters to accommodate the
computation for fhe the parameters are
selected once and for all so what is the
bootstrapping procedure so it can
refresh the ciphertext noise so in the
original construction of Gentry and in
the subsequent constructions every
sector ciphertext encodes a plaintext
together with some random values that we
call noise and the noise will increase
when we do computations and at a certain
point it will it will kind of mingle
with the plaintext so we cannot recover
the useful information and bootstrapping
is a procedure to kind of bring the
noise back to a small level so we can
still do more computation and for tfhe
at least for the
gates bootstrapping mode this
bootstrapping procedure is going to be
mandatory so we have to do the
bootstrapping after every gate and for
the other schemes is kind of more
flexible you can choose to do
bootstrapping in a more flexible way
where you you can have a computation as
so as a graph and you can select certain
nodes in the graph to perform
bootstrapping
so one of the analogies that that we
like to use is is that somewhat IHG to
me is like like a bow where you can
shoot the arrow to a certain distance
but if you want to increase the distance
then you need to upgrade your bow and so
effigy is kind of like a car where you
can you can go essentially arbitrarily
long distance as long as you feel your
gas tank once you know well and so so
why are people not using fhe so the
problem is that I said that eventually
that fhe is going to over perform
because it has a constant overhead but
the constant overhead is relatively
large because bootstrapping is very
expensive and there is a crossover over
point where fhe becomes more efficient
but it comes relatively late so for the
current applications people usually try
to fit the application into a
multivariate polynomials relatively
small degree so that in that regime cos
H he will outperform so that's the
landscape and so then I wanted to kind
of give some simple benchmarks to just
give people a feeling about how
efficient homomorphic encryption is
these days and so this is a design as a
matching game so we have private
information retrieval of 288 bite
message from a million entries
it takes about two point two seconds and
then we have prevacid intersection
between a set of 1,024 items and the
million items and it takes about four
point two three seconds and then we have
private inferencing of this newer
network called squeeze net no c14 it
takes about 22 minutes finally we have
training of logistic regression model of
about 400,000 samples and 200 features
so this is the largest task probably
I've seen and it takes about 70 hours
so and then in the next part of the talk
I will talk about some specific
applications that we have done using
homomorphic encryption and at this point
maybe I'll stop for some questions I
couldn't really see the Q&A tab here so
I wonder if there is a question I just
can't I just find it hard to read it
what is this and oh this centralization
this centralization I don't think I
mentioned that in my talk maybe I maybe
I mentioned it by mistake can you
clarify if you're using sh t SS
synonymous to LHC yes
so LHC refers usually to level H E and
in this talk I'm using as a CG but they
mean the same thing to me okay so I
don't see I need further questions so
let me continue oh here's another
question about cyber ten using which
scheme so this is done using psychic s
okay so in the next part I will talk
about the three applications of
homomorphic encryption that I promised
at the beginning so this slide is kind
of my personal timeline of working on
these applications and so we will talk
about the three applications in the
orange box so so first one I will talk
about is on the green Oh Ram so this is
oblivious Ram with constant
communication overhead so first let me
give a brief introduction to Iran so Oh
Ram is kind of
like a secure protocol where a client
wants to store an array of blocks to the
server and then read and write data from
the server
so the important privacy guarantee is
that first of all the server doesn't see
the data and all the data are encrypted
under the client secret key and the
second we also want to protect the
client read and write patterns also so
this is formalized by saying that any
two sequences of requests look
indistinguishable to the server so for
example the server doesn't know which
block the client is reading if the if
the client is reading some block and the
goal of aureum is to do this to achieve
these guarantees with sub linear
communication overhead and so I think in
a previous work without the H II it's
possible to achieve a poly logarithmic
overhead so what are the popular or an
architecture so one of the architecture
is that we store the data at the server
as a binary tree and then each tree
nodes can contain one or more encrypted
blocks and the client holds the
encryption key what the client also
holds is an address map which Maps each
block to some leaves of the tree and
then the client issues these access and
evict comments so access is one of the
read and write requests and if it is a
kind of like a shuffling procedure to
make sure that the the data czar are not
crammed in specific note okay so I'm
gonna give an example of some request
from a ram so after initialization the
Oh Ram could look like this where we
have eight blocks industry and the
client holds this position map in its
own memory
and what happens if the client wants to
access a block zero so it will first
find that the leaf is going to be zero
so it will read the path that led from
the root to the zeros leaf and then it
will download all the blocks from this
path and then decrypt them and read the
block it wants it will move back the
block to route and re-encrypt and write
the path back and also what it will do
is that it will assign a new uniformly
random leaf to this block so and then if
we want to access block one it's going
to be very similar so we download the
path and get the blog and write it back
to route and change its location and so
the interesting thing in this picture is
the big procedure so we have already
noticed that after the to access the the
root node is already full so we need to
do something to ensure that the blocks
are pushed to the leaves as much as
possible so in in an eviction procedure
we will just take a particular path and
try to push down the blocks in that in
that path downwards if possible so in
this case we have pushed the block
started with 7c - all the way down to
its leaf
so this leaves some some room for the
for the leaf sorry for the root okay so
that's a very quick introduction to all
Ram so what does it have to do with a
chi so we know that if we have the
standard OEM model then there is a
communication overhead lower bound of
log n so and this is this is proved so
it cannot be better than log n but in
2015
Devadas at all proposed this or am a
server computation model
which can achieve constant overhead so
this means that the server is not only a
storage block it and it can also perform
certain computations so the problem is
that construction is that it uses bgb
and dengar Jurek additive Hg but the
these two schemes are not tailored for
this kind of Orion computation so as a
result the efficiency is not very good
and this scheme was never implemented
and so one of the questions we asked is
that whether we can use faster
homomorphic encryption schemes tailored
at these or EMM tasks and so the answer
will be yes but first let's look at one
of the kind of central operation in this
Aram
so I think one of the most important
operation will be this oblivious
permutation so the setup is that the
client holds a permutation of n values
and the key the server will hold an
encrypted array encrypted under that key
and for the output the server should get
the permitted array which is still
encrypted under the same key so the way
to achieve this obliviously could be
using a permutation network so
permutation network is is realized by
connecting a bunch of cmoocs gates which
selects one of the two input from this
Delta which we also call twice bit so
one thing that we realized is that the
tfhe scheme which hilarya talked about
earlier today it can support this
so I'm going to be able to okay I
thought there was a question okay so let
me go back
yeah so one of our realizations were was
that the tfhe scheme supports efficiency
moobs operation between two types of
cypher text so it's GSW and ring RWE so
let me recall that civics operation a
little bit so the are GSW scheme looks
like a matrix where a cipher text has
more than one my one role and more than
one columns and riyo w/e encryption can
kind of be viewed as a vector so there's
a external product operation which takes
our g SW encryption of a and the r LW
encryption of B and outputs are out of
the encryption of a times B so the the
good thing is that if what's encrypted
inside is our g SW is actually a bit
then the noise growth of the result is
is additive so this means that we can
actually support many levels of stimulus
without having to increase their
parameters by a lot and if we apply this
to the permutation networks that just
mean that we need to use the r g SW to
encrypt the choice bit and using the REO
w/e scheme to encrypt the messages
so and how is it related to the to the
Orang case so notice that the OM
eviction is kind of oblivious
permutation because we want the client
to to tell the server to move certain
blocks down some paths but the server
shouldn't know which block is being
moved and how far should they move down
so what we can do to achieve this is
that the client will just package this
information as a permutation and then
send these choice bits of the
corresponding permutation network to the
server and the server will do the
oblivious permutation network evaluation
so what we have done some is some
benchmarks on how efficient is this
oblivious permutation and input so from
this graph we can see that it can be
better than the BGP were additive HT
counterparts for this specific task so
and then we put this together with some
other optimizations to achieve the final
system which is the onion ring or Ram so
as promised it has constant
communication overhead and it is
surprisingly also more cost efficient
than the state-of-the-art aureum schemes
for slow networks so this is the first
application and let me go to the second
one
okay so the second application we want
to present is all source private
inferencing from multi key Hg so what is
the use case that we want to support so
in this case we have three sets of
parties some data providers some model
providers who develop certain machine
learning models and a trusted server so
usually if we want to have this deserver
where the cloud hosts all these data and
models then for the privacy reasons this
data and model need to be encrypted but
then if the cloud also wants to perform
inferencing for these clients then it
actually requires decryption so there's
a adds to the privacy risks so if we use
a single key homomorphic encryption then
this will be a hard problem to achieve
but we have this primitive called multi
key homomorphic encryption and in
particular for the two key case we can
have each party encrypts its data or the
model using its funky and then the cloud
can actually provide the homomorphic
evaluation and then it's left to the
parties to jointly decrypt the result so
on what is multi key homomorphic
encryption so as mentioned previously we
always use a she to refer to the single
key setting where one client holds the
secret key and then can access all
encrypted information in a multi key
case it has the advantage that each data
contributor can use its own key
so the result of a joint computation
then can be decrypted jointly so in this
work our contributions are first we
provide a first implementation of multi
khe with packed ciphertext which means
that they can encrypt vectors and
perform coefficient wise operations
then we apply this scheme to oblivious
convolutional neural network evaluation
so here's a pictorial illustration of
multi key Hg so we have three parties
each encrypting its own data under its
own key
and then any party can take these
encryptions and perform a joint
computation which will be encrypted
under all three of the Q's and so all of
the three keys will be responsible for
decrypting the result
so what we have done in this work is to
give a multi kHz construction over over
ring so the ciphertext in our case will
be instead of a linear polynomial in
with one variable it will be a linear
polynomial in K variables where K is the
number of keys involved and the RQ which
is the base ring in our case will be the
this to power cycle atomic ray modulo Q
and we have the secret which is a vector
of size K and the decryption encryption
roughly looks like if we plug in this
secret into this linear polynomial it
will get encoded version of our message
so if we want to multiply two cipher
texts we just multiply the corresponding
polynomials but this is is not complete
because we get a polynomial of degree 2
and they consist of many cross terms si
SJ here so we need this procedure called
realization which was talked about
earlier in Young's talk because and this
can be used to reduce this quadratic
term back to linear so in the end what
we have is a city mall prime which is
again a linear polynomial and this
procedure is done by generating and
publishing realization key and the the
key has this property that if you plug
in this secret key vector it will be
equal to roughly the product of the two
secret key components so the question is
how do we generate these evaluation keys
because recall that this si belongs to
party I and as
J belongs to party J so so here's a PJ
narration procedure where each party
first publishes some information GI
related to its secret key and then
there's a public procedure which is
called eval keygen which generates the
necessary information for for the
evaluation key so so actually I have
written the the term G as seems like
it's a vector but actually each of the
component is a vector and G is a matrix
so this is the method that we started
with but then we realize that we don't
actually have to instantiate the
realization keys so this is because the
linearization procedure is kind of an
external product between the
corresponding term in the in a cipher
text after multiplication and the
evaluation key and the evaluation key
can be viewed as sort of internal
product between these two matrices and
it kind of has share some similarity
with the g SW ciphertext so in here what
we realize is that we can change the
order of operation but actually first
doing the external product with Gi and
then with GJ and because these
operations are associative so it
actually doesn't change the underlying
message so in this way we can achieve
two things simultaneously so first we
can reduce the memory overhead because
we never need to generate the K square
realization keys and second we can also
reduce the noise growth
so here's are some performance results
off our multi key homomorphic encryption
implementation is based on seal and we
can see that roughly the cipher text
operation complexity grows quadratically
with the number of parties as we have
expected and especially if we only have
a small number of parties then the
overhead is not too big compared to the
single key HT case and what we have done
is that we have initialized that idea of
doing the oblivious inference in a cloud
by having this analyst model inference
and we show that this inference can be
done using 2k 2k h e in about less than
two seconds
you
okay so let me check it first questions
how Orin could fix littlest Byzantine
for tolerance security I'm not sure
you
okay so let me continue and then the
third application I'll be talking about
and it's the final one today will be
militia secure and matrix multiplication
so so first of all let me just give a
very quick introduction to what is
militia security so in the secure
computation world we have different
threat models and semi honest security
means that the parties need to follow
the protocol description but they can
try to learn more by looking at the
protocol transcript militia security on
the other hand means that the protocol
needs to be secure even if parties can
arbitrarily deviate from the protocol so
this is a setting which is closer to
reality lots of bad guys out there but
it's harder to achieve and in
homomorphic encryption there has
actually been a lot of proposals for
efficient matrix multiplication
algorithms but it's only secured under
the semi on this setting and this kind
of feature shared by a lot of the
applications based on a cheat so what
about the malicious case in this case we
have the speed framework which can do
matrix multiplication but it will use n
cubed communication cost for doing
matrix multiplication on n by n matrices
so the question we ask is whether we can
get the best of both world by
efficiently combining a sheer is this
speech framework for NPC
so a quick review of the speech
framework is that in speed its operating
on a secret shared values but the secret
shares are in addition to an additive
secrecy we also have this alpha which is
the global message authentication key
and we have each party also holding this
Mac share which adds up to the Mac value
for this secret value X and a
multiplication triple in this case it is
just a triple of shares a B and C where
a b or random and C is equal to a times
B so these triples can be generated
offline and when we want to do some
secure computation they can be consumed
to perform multiplication and addition
will be done easily by just each party
adding the corresponding shares so I
won't mention it here so in order to
multiply secret values x and y the
parties just need to open X minus a and
Y minus B which hides the values x and y
but still allows parties to to obtain
the secret share of the result so this
is called also called beavers triples
and beavers multiplication trick so our
idea in this case is to generalize the
the previous slide 2 matrix triples so
we realize that this beavers trick
actually doesn't just work on
multiplication of scalars but it
actually works for any bilinear
operation so what we can do is that we
can utilize the state-of-the-art
HT matrix multiplication algorithm to
generate these matrix triples and the
the caveat here is that then we need to
use an HT scheme which supports more
levels or supports evaluating circuits
of higher depth and in a speed case it's
only using one level so we need to
actually increase the parameters for
speed
so and then let's first recall the HD
makes multiplication algorithm which i
think is pretty neat this is from CCS 18
and what we need to do is that in the
previous games for example PG b or c k
KS we need to actually express the
matrix multiplication efficiently as
coefficient wise vector operations
because that's what these schemes
support innately so if we assume that
the scheme has d square slots where D is
the dimension of each input matrix then
we can actually express the matrix
product as a summation of K terms sorry
D terms where each term is going to be a
rotation of a certain encoding of a and
B and the coefficient wise product of
the two so this is a really good
construction because complexity is
always almost optimal if we count the
complexity it's about D cubed poly
logarithm D so this means that it's
almost as good as the plain text matrix
multiplication
so what is our pipeline for generating
these matrix triples so what we will do
is that we will first have the parties
broadcast encryption of random matrices
with this zero knowledge proof of
knowledge which is from speeds and then
the parties will add up the ciphertext
to get encryption of random matrix a and
B and then they will use this algorithm
that we introduced earlier to compute
the product and then we can run the HT
multiplication to actually multiply the
Mac key to each of the three matrices
and finally do a distributed decryption
to obtain the triples so this pipeline
is very similar to the original speech
pipeline where they generate the Bieber
triples but the Delta is that we're
really using this state-of-the-art HT
matrix multiplication algorithms to to
make it efficient for a matrix triples
so we have another optimization in this
case by using a chi in a in a clever way
so we also can remove this so-called
sacrifice procedure of speeds so what is
this sacrifice so this is kind of a
technical set of steps where in the
speed case because it only supports
homomorphic encryption with level one so
after this step three the encryption of
this product is already kind of having
its noise maxed out so we need to do
actually this ressure procedure to
return a fresh encryption of the same
value and then we can multiply a with
Mac key to get authenticated shares of
these see the problem of this is that
the adversary can inject errors in this
reshare step so in the end the parties
could end up with a multiplication
triple with C not equal to a times B
it's not a valid triple but the parties
won't notice that so the sacrifice
procedure is going to resolve this issue
and what it does is that it will use
another triple to check this one so
effectively this introduces a two times
overhead because for every triple that's
produced there's another triple which is
sacrificed so the the sacrifice can be
removed easily by just having the hg
parameters be slightly larger so this
might not be a attractive option for
speeds because they aim to use low
parameters fresh efficiency but because
we already use larger hg parameters
since we need to do the matrix multiply
adding this support for one more level
won't be a big deal so in this new
picture we can remove the ressure
procedure and so this will give about
two times improvement on both
computation and communication so on this
slide we have some performance numbers
for matrix multiplication based on steel
so this is about multiplying matrices of
size from 128 to 1,024 and for two
parties in the militias case and we note
that for the square matrix of size 128
we have reduced a communication overhead
from one gigabyte to just 13 megabytes
and what we also estimated is that how
much communication will it need to
evaluate all linear layers of the rest
net 50 neural network and if we do it
use using speeds it will be one terabyte
of communication and doing this matrix
triples will reduce it to 41
gigabyte of communication and we have
noticed that also the the the timing in
terms of computation is also smaller in
terms of our algorithms
okay so I have talked about these three
applications and let me just mention
that I think if we want to apply these
this awesome
result in in a theoretical community to
practical applications then we need to
have good implementations and good
libraries so one of the libraries that I
have contributed to and used a lot is
this Microsoft CEO and I just wanted to
quickly mention that it recently rolled
out a new version 3.5 and it's open
source with under MIT license and has a
new Android support and there has been
actually a lot of application already
based on seal
so so just wanted to conclude by saying
that the homomorphic encryption can be
used to already build applications today
and my personal experience is that it
works best when you mix it with the
other technologies because it is good
for certain computations but maybe NPC
techniques are better for other
computations so usually a hybrid
protocol will achieve the best result
and I think there is also many
interesting challenges ahead so I won't
go into them in detail but I'll be happy
to to chat about this offline and that
concludes my talk thank you very much
thank you there's one question in the
Q&A about the network speed that he used
for the test runs okay are you talking
about these matrix multiplication tests
I think so doesn't say but I think so
okay okay so I think for the LAN setting
it's something like one gigabit and when
setting is maybe 10 megabytes or I could
be wrong so actually you can check the
paper and so recently put on a print run
time for M NIST is test amortized or
just single case I think it's single
case
in one single case just one image
prediction yeah thanks Mira I think well
one of the contribution of that is that
we actually have to fit the case a
single case into the ciphertext in order
to make it most efficient because it's
easy to make a patched case where is it
good through good but it's not so easy
to make a low latency result because we
need to utilize all the slots
efficiently there's another question
well the square layer affect the
accuracy yes it will but it it's not
affecting the accuracy by a lot how the
sir method for generating matrix triple
scale to multiple parties so it works
for multiple parties so we just
presented this performance results for
two parties but what we have in the
paper works for any number of parties
because that that's what the speeds
framework supports and we basically
follow the same framework do you have a
sense of how you know this accuracy
question right when you replace some
nonlinearities by squares is that in
general how does that you know you know
if you forget about I missed and support
and and support in general is there a
sense of how you know how this affects
accuracy yeah and I guess the second
part of this question is you know this
recent work of Ron Luca and the other
group where they they do the training
differently they creates the neural
network you know you know keeping in
mind that it's going to use squares or
follow menial approximations and they
don't replace all the real news by Paolo
meal approximations only most so is that
is that a possibility
to do as well yeah I guess so so I think
this is a very interesting open question
also for the machine learning community
to investigate and actually I have some
project collaboration with people from
our from our site how how to select
activation functions in order to to have
a good accuracy but also be secure
computation friendly so I haven't
actually read the paper that you
mentioned but yeah I think it's a it's a
good direction for yes because for the
for the polynomial approximation I think
one of the things that that can come up
is that we can have this overflow of
data because if we keep doing this
squaring it can it can get arbitrarily
large so that's one of the problem that
doesn't occur this really you know so so
I think yeah so we we need some way to
actually control the data to be on a on
on the same scale but if that's solved I
guess probably like they could just
start training the model using this
activation function so there won't be
too much accuracy loss when you later
evaluate them hmm
okay sounds good things so can really be
computed practically with C qks or B if
we or th e it can be computed but
whether it can be computed practically I
think it's it's based on each each
person's definition there's some recent
work which has the homomorphic
comparisons based on speak aks and I
think they have some good amortized
efficiency with the caveat that if
you're two numbers being compared to are
very close together then you can get
some errors so so you can use that to
build value definitely and the the
question would be then how would you
tolerate the precision loss but but yes
you can check out that word
are we able to train your network
homomorphic Li I'm not sure I don't
think there's published work in this
domain for now
because maybe mainly because it's still
relatively expensive because you you
probably have to do the bootstrapping
which makes it even more expensive
you
you
Oh
thank you very much how and thanks for
all the speakers of today and the
participants and we will see you again
tomorrow morning thank you